all right tony
yeah tony where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
um i grew up in new haven connecticut um
yeah
east coast and tell me about your family
uh with your parents uh yeah so i mean i
grew up with both my parents um
my mom uh was a housewife um
and my dad was a doctor he was super
super smart psychologist um
um
but um
i don't know he uh
he was super smart but like he was a
terrible business person so it was like
you know we always we were scrounging
for money my mama
was the one that kind of you know put
things together uh
he wasn't into sports he wasn't into you
know he didn't really you know out of
his own mouth he didn't like kids you
know
um
he uh
you know he's just a
very different person i feel like you
know
he didn't just like the life he was
living you know what i mean and um
and it was just reflective and and in
our interactions as kids you know my
brother my sisters and
and me and um
i think the the most um
damaging aspect of my childhood and um
uh
in growing up was the fact that uh my
dad was uh was gay and he was trying to
live a life of a straight man
um and you know he really
didn't like um
he didn't really didn't like that you
know he really wanted to live a life of
of what he felt was his natural
uh you know what he felt was natural to
him which was being gay you know and
this was back when um they believed that
you know you would pray uh you could
pray yourself out of homosexuality you
know like it was a disease of some sort
they
um you know this is
you know 79 you know early 80s
and uh
you know they would have prayer circles
with my family
and um you know he would pray about you
know
about you know relieving these thoughts
in his mind and whatnot and um
and you know what that came like i had a
father that didn't like sports who
didn't you know play catch who didn't uh
teach me how to shave who didn't
um really spend any time at all with me
the only time he did spend time with me
and my brother and even my sister was
when my mom would be just
passionately on his ass about doing it
you know
otherwise it would never happen you know
he just really
uh
i don't know he's just looking for an
escape and one day you know getting that
escape and after 25 years of marriage he
did find that escape and um
he left to move to palm springs
leaving my mom and uh
and coming out of the closet to uh to
the rest of us
which was a pretty gnarly which was a
pretty gnarly blow um
so
uh you know it's just it was a trip you
know i um
i i don't know if that was you know the
reason why you know things turned away
they did in my life i was you know like
at an early age i remember i was you
know i liked fire i liked firearms i
liked fireworks you know and those
things kind of drew me uh
and were much more interesting i had a
learning disability i was thrown out of
you know
five different high schools you know
i was always having a hard time in
school and
and uh you know
i moved out of my house when i was about
17
i was selling a lot of ecstasy
and uh you know i was i got up to where
i was selling uh
to the to the guys that managed the
clubs in hartford
and uh you know i would sell to the to
the guy who you know ran the club and he
would then distribute the ecstasy that
was house dealers and
and those were the only guys that were
allowed to sell the you know ian in
their clubs and uh
i did that for a while i uh
i ended up getting caught with 1200
ecstasy pills in connecticut and um
and you know as i'm doing as i'm doing
you know ecstasy it was like uh i
started doing uh
china white basically and that's what
they you know called it scramble china
white
we call it you know fentanyl now but um
uh you know you know i was like i was
always like a step ahead of like what
kids were doing you know i mean when i
was when i was growing up
and um you know
back then it was just a little you know
a little bit of powder
the size of a match head and i'd sniff
that and i'd be you know high for six to
eight hours you know
um
and it was great you know nobody ever
explained to me like there was you know
the addictive side to it that like
you know your body's gonna be physically
addicted to it i remember waking up and
telling you know just feeling like i had
the flu every day for months
and uh you know i explained it to a
friend you know man i keep you know
every time i wake up i have this flu i
have the flu every day and like
you know i was pretty naive to it and
and uh he was like you know you're dope
sick basically you know and that hit me
pretty hard like damn so i'm you know
i'm strung out you know and uh
you know at the time i like i said i was
selling a lot of ecstasy and then um
i was able to afford it and it was no
problem after i got arrested
for the 1200 pills i was able to bail
out pretty quick and uh
and now i'm kind of struggling you know
i have to go through you know boosting
or doing whatever i have to do to to get
my you know to get my drug and um
i had accumulated pretty good amount of
money and and uh i had accumulated some
some some things that you know slowly i
just sold off and uh
and then i uh was breaking into houses i
got caught uh
in a house uh i guess the the owners of
the home were upstairs and my friend you
know just jumped through the window and
um
they uh they called 9-1-1 immediately
and surrounded the house and um
and i was charged with a home invasion
and uh that was when home invasion just
came about you know and um
it was a pretty serious crime so i ended
up going to prison for that i got three
years
i was uh 21 years old and i went to uh
you know i was in connecticut and i went
through the connecticut department of
corrections and
um it was pretty it was pretty chill i
mean it was
you know got
you know there's not like gangs there
there's not i mean there's gangs there
but there's not like segregated gangs
it's not like whites hang out with the
whites blacks hanging over the blacks
and there wasn't any segregation like
that it was just uh
you know there was like four white boys
in a dorm of like 150 people and either
they were like dominican puerto rican or
black and
and uh you know i i was i wasn't you
know grown up to be racist or anything
like that it was just
connecticut it's just kind of a more of
a you know
like
a mixing pot and uh
i just got along with who i got along
with mostly it like was segregated in
neighborhoods
so um
so i hung out with kids from from my
neighborhood in my area um
but after you know when i was there for
about after doing a year i was able to
get parole for two years
and uh um
i got went to a halfway house and i was
there and um
i think i was there for about two weeks
before i started getting high again and
uh
i went to work one day and just decided
to jump on a bus and come out to
california my mom had moved out here
already
and um my brother had gone to cal poly i
had two older sisters that have been out
here for like 20 years and we'd go out
and visit them on vacations and [ __ ]
like that
and uh so so i got on a bus and just
decided to come out to california and
just never go back to connecticut again
you know so was my thought
and uh i um
i went out and uh you know i
got a california driver's license and
just figured that you know everything
was my past was behind me and i didn't
have to worry about connecticut at all
if i just didn't go back you know
and i've started getting high and i was
introduced to you know tar hero and then
and and um
and uh you know i it was good i enjoyed
it um
you know i i
was with a chick who was uh
her father was uh president of cnn
international and um
we didn't have to boost i didn't have to
do anything she just gave me her debit
card to go
you know withdraw money and and buy dope
which was a great thing
and uh
you know i was introduced to la and in
skid row and
and i just score and come back there and
uh you know she wasn't
she you know didn't really do heroin
before she mostly did math and uh so i
introduced her heroin unfortunately that
was my
my uh i don't know my sin and then uh
um you know we were getting high and and
she would fall out from time to time and
uh this one you know towards the end uh
you know and i would bring her back the
time she fell out but
towards the end of our relationship
there uh
she had fallen out
this one time and and i and i couldn't
bring her back you know i i
you know kept trying to resuscitate her
and she wasn't breathing and
so uh you know i called 9-1-1 because
you know i i know the you know
that she could have you know she could
die obviously so
i um
i uh
called 9-1-1 and and where we were
located was
you know it was like an apartment but it
was
it was kind of tucked away
uh so you couldn't really see it from
the street and i was afraid that the
ambulance wouldn't
wouldn't find the address and uh
so i you know i waited there and i went
out to the street to make sure that they
they would you know i could you know
show them where she was and uh you know
the cops came first and they weren't
really concerned with her at all
um you know they were more concerned
immediately with with who i was and and
my identity and whatnot
and um you know i uh
i
gave him a fake name and and uh you know
i didn't really think anything of it
they went into the apartment and
searched the apartment
uh paramedics finally came uh they
couldn't bring her back at at first
there
um they put in brought her in to the
hospital
and um
um you know they found an id with my id
uh with my name on it and whatnot and i
had a you know felony fugitive warrant
for escape in the first degree for um
for walking out of that work release
program
you know on the way to jail um
the cop told me that they were able to
revive her and bring her back to life
and uh you know if they hadn't they
would have shot they were going to try
to charge me with manslaughter but
so you know um
i uh
you know i never never saw that girl
again after that but uh um you know i
went and did the other two years
in connecticut
and um
and
came out to california permanently
and uh you know when i was doing drugs
in um
in connecticut like
you know
if you're gonna sell drug you know
heroin or anything like that you have to
you don't have to get permission you
know from from gangs that you know latin
kings are
different gangs a couple different gangs
that out there there that run
neighborhoods and stuff like that and uh
and santa barbara is just kind of open
like you know it's not like you can just
go onto a street
and uh buy you know buy drugs on the
street it was uh
you have to know somebody to know
somebody and
and you know it became pretty hectic so
i you know immediately as as fast as i
can get a large amount of money put
together so you know six seven hundred
dollars put together you know i bought
uh a amount of drugs and and began you
know just selling it out here and and uh
you know that worked out really well for
for a long time uh
you know i ended up uh
i ended up getting arrested i was out
here for about five years
before um before i ended up
you know getting caught up in
sales and transportation i uh i remember
i was
leaving a hotel room at like two o'clock
in the morning arguing with this chick
and uh
i sped out of the hotel and um you know
i spun the tires
and a cop saw me he was coming out of a
7-eleven and you know i started running
to his car so i knew he was gonna you
know chase me
and i um you know took the cops on
high-speed chase down state street in
santa barbara
you know almost crashed a couple times i
finally uh
i finally did crash and um
you know i folded the left i was taking
a right-hand turn and i filled the left
tire underneath the car and
front tire underneath the car and uh
and
you know was immobile i was trying to
put the car in drive when the cops had
surrounded the vehicle with their guns
drawn and [ __ ]
you know not not thinking that you know
they would have definitely shot me if i
had gotten that car and drive you know
um
and they ended up pulling me out of the
winch out of the window of the car and
uh and you know he handcuffed me up and
uh i sat in jail for like nine months
for that i i got a sales and
transportation i had a couple ounces of
heroin a couple ounces of meth in the
car
uh scales baggies uh
um
and the girl that i was with had claimed
that she had hurt her neck
so i got a dui with injury which was uh
any crime involving a um a victim it
gets a little more serious you know
and um
uh
you know i don't know it uh
i sat in jail for for uh for nine months
uh 10 months and uh
i got a uh
i ended up getting a nine year
joint suspension um
uh
four year three years probation felony
probation nine-year joint suspension and
um
i uh
i um i got out and i
was supposed to go to delancey street
and as soon as i got out i immediately
started getting high um
even though i hadn't
the nine year form on joint suspension
and um
you know i was picked up four days after
i was released
in a dope house that got raided and uh
um
i uh
you know i told him at court that you
know i'm a serious drug addict you know
and that
that i needed to be transported to the
program
and
when i was in there the program that
initially accepted me
said that i wasn't allowed to go back
because i didn't go there when i was
supposed to
so
i was released they gave me 90 days and
that they were going to transport me to
the program and after the 90 days had
happened
no one had picked me up and brought me
so i was released on my own again
i went to my uh to my sister's house
and she brought me to the santa barbara
rescue mission and i went there and
and um
i got on the waiting list to go in there
i checked in with probation parole
and they said if i had gotten in and
then they would they would let me come
in and uh
you know i finally got my time came and
i got to bed and i went there and i went
through the whole program and and i got
sober for a little while and um
from there i went to a sober living
after i graduated the rescue mission i
went to a silver living house
you know i met a girl who i thought was
you know amazing and uh
you know we ended up getting married i
uh
it's you know it was
shortly after we got married
she she kind of just changed on me and
um she just came extremely like
ungrateful about um
about everything you know we had a nice
house and you know car i was going to
school to be a barber
and um
and like i you know i had never had it
so good you know
and um
and she just was she was complaining
about you know me not being around
enough i would go to the gym you know
i'd go to meetings and
and my days were pretty pretty full you
know with school and everything as well
and then i had a job at a barber shop as
well
so i slowly stopped doing things you
know i stopped going to meetings i
stopped uh
you know
meeting with my support groups and
whatnot and
you know finally after a little while of
that an idea came to mind that you know
i'm gonna i'm gonna show this girl how
how grateful she is and i'm gonna get
high for a weekend
at the time i was um i was sober for
about three and a half years
and uh and
i was you know my thought was yeah and
i'm gonna get high for the for a weekend
i'm gonna be able to stop it after that
and uh
and and i'll show her and then she'll be
scared and know what i'm like on drugs
and not want me to do that and
it'll all work out and
you know that weekend has lot lasted
like six years now
um you know i as soon as i picked up i
haven't been able to you know stop uh
you know
um
like they say one is too many and a
thousand is never enough you know
and uh you know i've
been in and out of jails and you know
i've
you know prison i had gone back to
prison since then and
and um you know we recently recently got
divorced and uh
it was my
i got a prison term
i've been out of prison for like seven
months now and um
and about nine months into it she just
absolutely stopped calling and whatnot
and at that point it was like it wasn't
you know it wasn't uh surprising to me
you know we'd gone through so much she
had one at one point she had
she had shot herself and uh because she
was
uh
she was in so much pain she was going to
doctors and and getting you know medical
scripts from doctors for pain medication
and a doctor finally caught on to her
and and let the other doctors in her
insurance group know that you know she
felt that she was abusing the system and
getting prescription medications uh
you know just because she's addicted and
which it was true and
and um but she swore at this time she
wasn't you know just trying to get
medication she was serious and
and you know she was in so much pain she
decided to shoot herself so
um you know that thinking kind of
just i don't know just trying to make
sense of something like that just was
beyond me and
and uh
you know i uh and i dealt with you know
not that's that's serious but similar
thinking you know through for for seven
years of our marriage and uh
and uh you know just i'm an extremely
loyal person whether you know
i should be you know whether i should
have been in that relationship or not
you know
was was not a question it was just i was
there and i was doing it you know and
and uh
and you know codependency and whatnot it
was just
just
just it was just a polluted sick
relationship you know so after being in
prison for nine months and then totally
losing contact with her i just assumed
that you know she had moved on and
whatnot which she had you know um
and uh
you know she um
you know it was it was a it was a pretty
serious loss for me you know um
it was just something that i was so used
to and it was so uh
uh i don't know it was just so you know
i was so addicted to it as well you know
but um
uh yeah i i
so i you know i get out of prison and i
i start you know just doing the same
thing you know as i as i've been doing
you know i uh
i just start getting high and
i ended up getting a pretty serious
infection um
and my arm started my forearm and uh
it spread to my bicep and then went from
my bicep to my
to my leg and then my calf
or my calf and then my quad and and i
finally couldn't walk and
at this time i'm doing uh fentanyl uh
just straight fentanyl
and i it and it finally stopped working
for the pain you know and i couldn't
move at all
and i went to the hospital and i had you
know several abscesses deep in my in my
calf and i they had to drain that i
ended up
in surgery for like i had like five or
six surgeries where i went under
for them to drain these uh to drain my
leg and my arm and um
and uh
yeah it was pretty it was pretty intense
you know
but it you know it wasn't too intense to
where when i got out i didn't you know i
went directly back
to doing the same thing you know um
and uh
you know i um
now i've uh you know i've
pretty much
moved out here to la and i've just been
you know staying with friends and people
and uh
you know just continue to
you know do it do what i do you know and
uh
and uh you know i don't know what really
what i'm waiting for or
what there is to
happen next you know um
but uh
i don't know it's just uh i'm just
taking it you know
just a little bit just a little bit at a
time to try to figure it out you know
um
but uh
yeah
it can get pretty intense out here but
how's your relationship with your family
um
i i don't i don't speak to them at all
when i'm when i'm getting high
i pretty much just
they kind of know what you're going
through uh yeah they after years of
dealing with it it's like i mean i don't
know if they don't it's not that they
don't want to hear it you know i'm sure
they want to hear from me and whatnot
but i just i just
feel so much such like [ __ ] that i just
don't i don't call them it's just a
shame that keeps you from
yeah basically reaching out
basically yeah
you're the only one in your family that
has this yeah yeah i've um three older
sisters a brother and are you the black
sheep yeah for sure yeah
yeah is there is it drugs or addiction
in your parents my dad's an alcoholic
like i said yeah he's
and now you know he got sober for about
10 years but i guess he started
taking norco's and he's strung out on
pain pills now so
yeah
do you see what you are going through is
it some kind of maybe you inherited that
from your dad
uh yeah i mean
i mean it was it was awkward you know my
dad was awkward extremely awkward and
made things pretty pretty uncomfortable
uh it was like walking on eggshells
around him you know what i mean um
um
you know but
yeah i mean he's not he's an alcoholic i
mean the
addictive gene you know
had passed from him to me i'm sure yeah
what kind of emotions do you do you deal
with
other than the shame that you mentioned
um i have severe anxiety um
i uh i have i have depression um
you know i i
i would say typical
typical uh
feelings for for a person and you know
where i'm at you know um
yeah i've always had anxiety i've always
had depression um you know when i got
sober though it seemed the more i got
just the longer i was sober the
the less those things you know surfaced
you know so
you know at one point needing medication
like
um
you know to to a point where
it just kind of goes away on its own
when i'm the longer i'm able to stay
sober but i just just getting back to
being sober has just been impossible you
know
have you tried
i mean have you
how was it was the longest
run you've had of being clean uh three
and a half years three years
yeah
and fentanyl such a hard one too
it's hard to get that start you know
it's really hard to just get that start
and um
you know there's a lot of places out
here that i've heard that um you know
hotels that'll you know
that give you rooms and help you get um
you know low income housing so
yeah i'm hoping you got signed up with
one of those places at some point
told you
i'm 42. do you have kids no i don't
think god
yeah they wouldn't
he wouldn't be of much use to being a
dad like this yeah for sure
i wonder if it would be any different if
i did
probably not
your friends
um
man i thought i did you know i thought i
did but um
you know my um my wife definitely showed
me that i i don't have any friends um my
ex-wife showed me that i definitely
don't have friends a lot of them
you know would try to
would try to pursue her you know
you know behind my back and she'd let me
know and um it was pretty upsetting
pretty sad you know
i have a lot of acquaintances i'm you
know but i wouldn't say i have any
friends at all now
what regrets do you have
um
probably probably relapsing um when i
had that three and a half years my
biggest regret um allowing somebody to
have some kind of power in my life to
where
i'm making my decisions you know based
on uh
you know coming from some you know
codependent you know weak place you know
well would you say that the addiction i
mean you started early yeah
i i still i started
i started doing heroin when i was about
um 17 18.
would you say the addiction just
i mean how how powerless are you
in in the addictions derailing of your
life
um did you have dreams of doing
something when you were a teenager
no i see i mean
i was
i was doing drugs ever since i could
remember you know and um you know i was
selling drugs as as early as i can
remember to going through high school
and whatnot
and uh
you know i just figured i would just do
that for for
you know
forever you know i didn't
you know i didn't really think of like
being a you know a professional baseball
player or you know i didn't think of
being a lawyer or something like that
you know
um
so
you know i don't know i don't know it's
weird
would you describe yourself as happy or
unhappy
um i wouldn't say i'm happy um
you know i'm not uh
i don't know really what i'm
you know what i'm looking for next you
know i mean i i have some ideas you know
i have some ideas of what i'd like to do
you know i
you know i'd like to get back into
cutting hair and stuff um
during that infection that i had i i got
gout in my knee so i can't stand very
long
so i wouldn't be able to cut hair
on top of that i don't have the tools to
do it either
but
you know i would like to get into one of
these
hotels that that um
that you know house you and
and get some resources and look towards
getting back into that you know yeah
having a little stability might help you
yeah some spelling would spilling yeah
living on the streets and just
scrambling day after day night after
night just yeah makes it hard to
yeah yeah
it's been it's been a pretty cold winter
yeah it's been
just just living on the streets is just
a terrible yeah situation in order to
get your life together yeah sometimes i
have to yeah stay on the street
and it sucks
i mean i'm really i really i don't sleep
anymore i don't i don't go to bed
anymore per se i might pass out you know
um they get robbed and some sometimes
yeah well a lot of times i
i learned that pretty quick um
you know it's easy to ride somebody
who's deep in sleep what's that it's
easy to rob some steel oh yeah oh yeah
for sure you get all your stuff stolen
off
yeah i've i've heard stories of people
just getting everything completely
everything taken from them you know
um
you know i uh
you know i like to say i know my limits
and stay within a realm of being high to
where
um you know where what's going on around
me you know or you know i know where
there's a safe place to sleep or you
know
and where when there's not a safe place
to sleep you know
um and i haven't had to you know go
through being robbed or anything like
that but
you know maybe a little bit of drugs you
know
you know left in my pocket you know
which yeah but yeah you know it's it's
pretty gnarly it gets pretty pretty
savage out here
boosting yeah pretty much boosts um it's
like 90 of
the fentanyl addicted population i would
say um
i and then i you know use the dope that
i that i get i i'll get high with that
and then sell that off as well and so
your typical day you wake up and you got
to get well
uh yeah yeah with fentanyl it's got an
extremely long half life to it so i
don't really wake up sick
like i did when i was doing heroin you
know um
i think my body's in general you know
i've been able to put up
i have put so much in my system that
that it'll probably take me a couple
days uh solid days before i really get
sick you know what are the differences
between heroin and fentanyl
um heroin is a short-lasting
um
[Music]
a shorter lasting
you know half-life like
you know i generally would do a you know
quarter to a half gram a shot
and uh you know i would stay high for
you know
probably
i don't know six to
six to eight hours
uh with fentanyl i i could do
you know twenty dollars a heroin
or twenty dollars of fentanyl and
you know smoke it not have to shoot up
which is great
and um and i'll stay high for about
about i don't know i could probably stay
not sick well a whole day but
i'll probably stay high for about
you know eight hours
uh six to eight hours just about
um
i mean it's a lot stronger phenol it's
pretty much brings you to the state of
you know nodding you know
i know when i'm high as as soon as i
stop start just like dropping my foil or
you know
dropping the apparatus i'm smoking out
of you know um
or just you know going into just nods
you know that's pretty much when i stop
um
yeah do you think you'll be down here
the rest of your life
um
yes yeah i mean it could you know um
i know i was asking myself you know the
other day like am i just waiting for the
next bag to where you know that'll kill
me you know am i is that what i'm
waiting for because
because i'm just doing the same things
over and over again you know and
and uh
you know it's just that's a real option
you know i could just uh
i could just be getting high until that
bag you know because people
so many people die off of fentanyl you
know and um like why haven't i you know
i haven't died from it yeah you know
when i first got out of prison i
overdosed a few times and that was when
i was doing heroin that was cut with
fentanyl and uh i was muscling it i
wasn't sticking in my vein i was
sticking to my shoulder you know and um
and you know i would
fall out 15 you know about 15 minutes
after i
did the shot i would fall out and uh
you know it was a trip and you know i
i three times in a week i fell out and
you know one time a friend had brought
me back
and the other two times i'd go to the
hospital
and um
you know now i'm just smoking straight
fat and about
about a hundred dollars of fentanyl a
day
give or take
what are you afraid of
what's your biggest fear
going to jail kicking
detoxing yeah
detoxing in la county jail would
probably be the biggest my biggest fear
and i kind of approach whatever i do
like illegally
with that in mind you know
so
i'm pretty much willing to do
you know whatever to not
go go to jail you know
so they don't help you with your
addiction
that will help me with my they don't
help you with your addiction the jails
yeah no there's no
methadone there's nothing
yeah i mean yeah there's i guess they're
doing suboxone now but
i heard suboxone doesn't even really
affect you know fentanyl detox because
it's so serious you know
i'm just i know i haven't kicked i
haven't kicked i haven't been sick since
i started doing fentanyl you know it's
almost it's been about almost a year you
know
and uh
yeah so
it's pretty gnarly what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in all of this
um
i don't know
um
that i don't know that is stagnant and
it's boring your life might feel like it
is when you're sober or
you know
um
that you know just just to stick it out
you know
it's a lot harder to
to get sober than it is to stay sober i
guess
and um
and
um
you know if you're sober and you're
struggling with you know whether or not
you're going to relapse or
whether you you know it's worth it or
whatnot
just know that and you know it's
definitely better to be silver than to
be
using you know you don't know what twist
or turns your mic like your life might
take and
um you don't know how ugly it can get
you know
um you know in my all my addiction i've
never
had it as bad as i have it now you know
and uh is this your lowest point right
now oh yeah for sure
yeah for sure i never had to go you know
steal from stores or anything like that
and i was always pretty
you know although i could do it and i'm
you know pretty good at it i guess but
you know i don't know i you know i sold
drugs to do drugs and
and
uh and uh
you know now it's just i'm just
you know
just doing just
just
stealing from
you know anywhere to to survive you know
it's pretty gnarly
that's pretty ugly
all right tony thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah thank you for
having me i appreciate it thank you very
much
you